this young guy loved investigating
paranormal activities and creepy
historical events but his hobby turns
into a nightmare when he gets sucked
into another dimension full of zombies
Ash is a friendly man with a regular job
but an unfortunate event changed his
life completely he had a lovely
girlfriend named Linda they both were
interested in exploring creepy places
and found an abandoned Cabin in the
Woods a few years ago an archaeologist
used to live in this cabin to translate
and study his latest Discovery called
The Book of the Dead he left the book
there and Ash found it and explored it
along with Linda it was bound in human
flesh and written with blood the
Sumerian text inside the book contained
bizarre burial rights funerary
incantations and Demon Resurrection
passages it was never meant for the
world of the living the book awoke
something in the woods which took away
Linda it also came after Ash and
infected his hand Ash didn't give up and
cut off his hand with a chainsaw to stop
the infection from spreading through his
body he survived survived that time but
after a few days it came for him again a
portal opened in front of the cabin and
sucked in Ash in his car he lands in the
middle of a desert where the people
dress like ancient warriors Ash tells
them he meant no harm and just wants to
return home some of the people assume
that he is the one who was mentioned in
the Book of the Dead he was prophesied
to fall from Heaven but others accuse
Ash of being with an enemy named Henry
they chain him and drag him to the
castle everyone gathers to honor their
leader named Lord Arthur afterward they
open a deep pit in which the criminals
are thrown as a punishment Ash is put
forward along with Henry who immediately
recognizes that Ash is not one of his
men Henry is the lord of the Northlands
and the sworn enemy of Lord Arthur both
of the lands are cursed by a mysterious
evil entity but Lord Arthur has blamed
Henry and started a war now he wants to
kill Henry by throwing him in the pit to
demonstrate how dangerous it is Arthur
orders his men to throw another captive
first as soon as the captive falls in
the pit a fountain of Blu Reese is out
of the pit proving that the poor captive
faced a tragic de another captiv a Tre
is running away but Arthur kills him
skillfully with an arrow There's No
Escape now it's Ash's turn he starts
begging the guards to let him go as he
doesn't even know Henry or any other of
them however no one listens to him and
Ash is thrown into the pit he falls in a
puddle of water with several caves
around him suddenly a zombie emerges
from the water and attacks Ash with his
deadly claws moreover two walls full of
sharp spikes gradually come closer to
crush Ash he is fighting the zombie
while the people above are enjoying the
show suddenly a mysterious old man
brings the chainsaw from the car and
gives it to Ash he joins the chainsaw on
his arm and kills the zombies afterwards
he pulls out his belt and hangs on the
Rope to get out of the pit Ash also gets
his shotgun from the car and uses it to
scare the people they all fall before
his power and start respecting him as
their lord Ash gets fed with lots of
food and several gorgeous women look
after him he calls the wise man of the
Kingdom to ask him how he can go back
home the Wise Man reveals that Ash has
traveled back in time and only the Book
of the Dead can help him it has a
passage which must be recited to open
the time portal however the book is lost
and only Ash can get it back to save the
kingdom the conversation is interrupted
by an old lady who has also turned into
a zombie she attacks everyone but Ash is
not scared at all he grabs his shotgun
and defeats the zombie the wise man begs
him to help in getting the Book of the
Dead before it falls in the hands of the
zombies otherwise the whole of humanity
will be wiped out by evil Ash agrees and
takes help from the blacksmiths to build
a metal hand for himself so he can
easily fight with the zombie a young
girl named Sheila is really impressed
with his bravery she visits him at night
to give best wishes for the quest Ash
admits that he is going on this Quest
just because he wants to use the book to
return home however the feelings he is
developing towards Sheila are real and
he gives her a goodbye kiss the next
morning the wise man takes Ash to a
creepy place and shows him a path it
will lead him to an Unholy place and
there he will find a cemetery where the
Book of the Dead is kept while picking
up the book Ash must recite these words
clat verat nikto the wise man tells Ash
to repeat after him a few more times to
remember the words but Ash refuses to do
as he trusts his memory he rides his
horse on the scary path which takes him
to a thick forest Ash feels that someone
is following him so he rushes to find a
safe place the horse runs so fast that
Ash falls off and lands in a puddle the
creepy thing is still after him so he
keeps running blindly Ash finds a
windmill and hides inside the mysterious
creature keeps banging on the door for a
while and then it disappears Ash looks
around and finds a weird mirror he
breaks the mirror in Terror but a tiny
clone of Ash emerges out of each piece
of the broken mirror they are extremely
naughty and try to find several ways to
tease Ash firstly they pick up a fork
and hit it on Ash's butt then they get
on the shotgun and start firing in the
air Ash gets really angry and kills one
clone with a fork and crushes another
one with his foot the remaining clones
attack him together and make Ash Fall
unconscious when he wakes up he assumes
that it was just a nightmare then he
tries moving his body but fails he has
been tied to the ground by the Clones
they forcefully open his mouth and one
of the Clones jumps inside the mouth he
starts running around in Ash's stomach
and makes him sick Ash is really
frustrated because of the Clone and he
drinks burning hot water to kill it the
stomach feels calmer for a while but
then after feels something hurting his
shoulder there is a human eye forming on
the shoulder Ash runs out of the
windmill to look for help the eye on his
shoulder turns into a head and then into
a whole identical clone of Ash the Clone
calls himself the bad Ash and starts
torturing the real Ash who shoots him
with the shotgun the Clone hasn't died
yet so Ash takes him inside and uses his
chainsaw to cut the Clone into several
pieces afterward Ash buries the Clone
but the head keeps talking and warns of
his return Ash isn't scared and proceed
proceeds to complete his quest he finds
the cemetery which the wise man
mentioned Ash looks around and finds the
high spot where the book must be kept
surprisingly there are three identical
books and only one of them can be
real Ash opens the first book which
sucks him inside a weird portal when Ash
comes out of it his face changes into a
funny appearance Ash shakes his head to
get back his face and then he starts
thinking which book he should choose
next Ash randomly grabs one but it has
teeth and bites Ash after getting rid of
the wrong ones Ash proceeds towards the
actual Book of the Dead But Ash suddenly
remembered that the wise man told him to
recite the words Ash tries to recall the
exact words but fails he can't remember
the last word Ash assumes that maybe the
dead are not listening carefully they
may not notice if he says the words
slightly wrong Ash picks up the book
while reciting the words at first
everything seems fine but then the sky
gets cloudy and it begins to rain with
severe thunderstorms heavy winds are
blowing and the ground is is shaking Ash
tries to sneak out of the cemetery but
because of the mistake he made the dead
emerges from the graves the skeletons
pull Ash down on the ground and play
with his face Ash somehow gets out of
the cemetery and heads back to the
castle the people celebrate to see their
hero returning with the book Ash asks
the wise man to fulfill his promise and
send him back home but the wise man
keeps asking if Ash said the words while
picking up the book or not Ash admits
that he may have said the word slightly
wrong the wise get enraged and tell Ash
that his mistake has put the whole
Kingdom in danger the army of the dead
has awoken Ash doesn't care and asks to
send him back home as soon as possible
Lord Arthur reaches there too and orders
his men to pay back the favor as
promised Sheila sees this all as well
and asks Ash if he is not going to help
them like a true hero when Ash refuses
Sheila calls him a coward and she walks
away meanwhile the Clone which Ash had
buried also jumps out of the Grave to
lead the army of the Dead a flying
zombie reaches the kingdom and takes
away Sheila the Clone makes her a zombie
too and calls Sheila as his wife they
have reached the cemetery where the
skeletons are all helping their fellows
and coming out they are turning into a
huge power army Ash can't just leave
these people in danger as they trusted
him as their hero he stands up on the
tower and advises everyone not to run
away Ash is also ready to lead the
Kingdom on this Mission everyone
including Lord Arthur agrees Ash goes
back to his car and takes out everything
he can find in the trunk it also has a
chemistry book and Arthur uses it to
make
gunpowder he also separates his car
parts to make a new vehicle suitable to
be used in war next day Ash keeps making
modern style weapons and teaches others
how to use them they are fully prepared
for the war they have locked the Book of
the Dead in a cage as it is what the
zombies want afterwards the soldiers set
around the castle to guard it the army
of the Dead reach there and start
marching towards the castle while
holding thick wooden Shields Ash has
made special arrows full of gunpowder as
the soldiers throw these arrows on the
skeletons their Shields are destroyed
then they prepare the cannon and shoot
toward the enemies at first it seems
like the humans have won but the
skeletons are too many in number and
it's not possible to kill someone who is
already dead the skeletons use a huge
tree to break into the castle they fight
face to face with the knights and start
taking the lead suddenly Ash arrives
there on his self-made cart which has
sharp blades on it to kill the skeletons
everyone starts cheering for him while
he defeats several skeletons suddenly
Ash notices Sheila and he loses his
concentration the cart flips over and
Ash Falls in a corner he is still
willing to fight and grabs some random
weapons to attack the zombie Sheila some
of the skeletons have already started to
climb up the tower to steal the book
lord Arthur doesn't have enough guards
there but then he sees someone coming
for help it's Henry and he has also
brought his army seeing this the Clone
decides to get the book by himself Ash
stops him with continuous attacks more
zombies get there and now Ash has to
fight all of them together Ash lights
fire on the Clone and throws him off the
building the other zombie grabs the book
but Ash puts the zombie on a cannon and
shoots him into the sky the rest of the
zombies and skeletons give up and
Retreat while Sheila turns back normal
Henry and Arthur have joined hands and
they start planning a United and
prosperous kingdom the wise man prepares
a potion using the Book of the Dead he
instructs Ash to drink this potion while
saying specific words and he will return
to his time Ash says goodbye to Sheila
and gets back to his presence
several days have passed since the
incident but Ash still shares his
experience with his friends they have
one question did Ash say the words
correctly while drinking the potion
actually no he made a mistake that has
brought the curse to his time he may
encounter zombies quite often throughout
his life but now Ash knows how to deal
with them